[Music]
a neighboring village it's a project for
us gen Abel the agency that supports
people with disability so together with
a stable while we work together to
reimagine the previous pokey mera
Vocational Institute to become the
enabling village enabling village is
located in the heart of the matura hue
neighborhood there is a lack of
community focus as well as amenities our
proposal is really to open up my
community heart with variety and
diversity to cater for everyone and in
the sense we hope to cultivate a sense
of calm Punk spirit through the village
there's a lot of open space but they are
all neglected and inactivated so our
design proposal introduced a lot of
greenery and landscape to activate this
space this includes providing Ram's
amenities lives and useable
multifunctional common space that not
only engages the tenants but also the
neighborhood so this become a shared
space where the neighborhood can come
together to use to interact and to bond
the making of the village and its spaces
is driven by the needs and aspirations
of the users and as architect the end
user experience is very important so
it's really about breaking down barriers
and opening up to engage and to enable
people with disability as equals in the
society so we hope that with this award
and a bring village will continue to
inspire a more humane livable and
sustainable society
[Music]